بحسب جولد اكثر من 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام
كامل حول العالم ستتاثر نتيجه التطورات
المتسارعه في حقل الذكاء الاصطناعي وبحسب
وظيفه عامل المصنع تاتي على راس هذه
القائمه في الوظائف المهدده في الاختفاء
بفعل الذكاء الاصطناعي حيث قد تسد
الروبوتات مكان العاملين كذلك وظيفه السعي
او موصل الطلبات قد تختفي مستقبلا حيث
تتجه الى الاتمته واستخدام الروبوتات بشكل
متسارع والتجارب تحقق نجاحا ملفتا ولن
يكون هناك مكان لمحللي البيانات
والاستثمار فهؤلاء سيكون الاستغناء عنهم
بالتعاون مع الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي سيصبح
قادرا على جمع وتحليل وتصنيف البيانات
بافضل طريقه ممكنه وكذلك فان وظيفه خدمه
الزبائن ستكون عرضه الانتهاء بشكل كبير
بسبب الروبوتات التي تحتل مكان العاملين
فيها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاش تراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات